Muchas gracias.
Tengo una historia que contaros.
Cuando bajé del avión,
después de un largo viaje desde el oeste de Inglaterra,
mi ordenador, mi querido portátil,
se había vuelto loco
y había...¡Ah!...¡Algo así!
y la pantalla...
...bueno, se rompió todo.
Fuí a ver a los chicos de Tecnologías de la Información
y un caballero arregló mi ordenador
y me preguntó: "¿Qué te ha traído aquí?"
y le dije: "Vengo a tocar el chelo y a cantar un poco"
él dijo: "Yo también toco el chelo"
Y yo le dije: "¿En serio?"
Y aquí está, para pasar un buen rato
porque ¡es fantástico! Se llama Mark.
(Aplausos)
Me acompaña también mi cómplice, Thomas Dolby.
Esta canción se llama "Más lejos que el sol".
(Música)